I'm just not good at dating,
I tried it on for a little while
and for everyone's better life
I've taken myself
out of the game
and then loads of people in my
life want me to get back into
the game
Why? Why do I have to be
like you? If I were this bad
at anything else... if I was
a surgeon
who managed to kill every
patient and burn down the
Palliative Care Unit
I'm pretty sure my friends and
family wouldn't be like
"Katherine, when are you gonna
get back in the emergency room,
girl?
I was the only child in the
world who believed their mother
when she said
"they're just jealous,
Katherine" I was like "girl,
I know"
They could have victimised any
girl in the school, but they
chose me
and one other girl with a cleft
palate and one leg
but we were the Kim and Kanye
of the fourth grade
Meghan Markle... I'm supposed
to like her, even though
she took the only viable
ginger cock of the market
and that cut me very deep
They're absolutely amazing, they
have beautiful children
and all their children somehow
look like them, even though
they themselves don't look
like them
When I was heartbroken during
my breakup
Khloé was also going through
a breakup with her then husband
NBA star Lamar Odom
but she didn't cry in her room
like I cried in my room
Khloé got in the gym and she
started working out, lifting
weights
and I thought "woah, here
we go, revenge body
she's gonna bulk up, be drafted
by the NBA, beat him at his
own game"
I remember one evening I was in
bed and I overheard my father
calling my mother a whore
and I had a great sense of
justice, so I appeared at the
top of the stairs
in my jammies and I said "daddy"
and he said "yes" and I said
"Grandma's a whore"
"How do you like it when someone
calls your mother a whore?"
He did not, he did not
I have a beautiful daughter,
who's British!
and I really recommend having
an English child
it's like having a tiny,
ineffective butler at home
She's got me feeling like
the Fresh Prince all day
just like, "oh I'm ever so
sorry mummy, I appear to have
mashed Nutella into the carpet
again"
I'm like "yeah you did, you're
the shittiest butler in
the world
but I love you, and hey where's
mummy's drink though?"
"Oh, I do apologise mummy,
would you like a day wine
or a night wine?"
Isn't that so cute? She thinks
white wine is for the day and
red wine is for the night
She's not wrong, is she?
They'll be YouTube videos going
viral, have you seen these?
40 million views!
"Incredible Dad learns to braid
his own child's hair"
and women all over the globe
would lose their shit
they'd be like "Oh my god,
Michelle, Don, get over here
have you heard about this
incredible single dad?
Where is he?
Is anyone sucking him off
right now? Can I go next?
There are two people who are
known to have left Sarnia
there's me and then heroic
Canadin astronaut,
Chris Hadfield
Everyone loves Chris
Hadfield, he has millions of
Twitter followers
they named an asteroid, two
schools and an airport after him
There are far more interesting
people from my hometown
How about my friend Elizabeth?
She overdosed on Fentanyl
sixteen times
Still alive,
still doing Fentanyl
What a hero!
Or my other friend, Mandy Kay,
she jerked off three hockey
players in the space of an hour
and they went on to win the game
Where's her airport?
Has anyone taken one of these
tests where you spit in a tube?
I took the test, and they asked
me to take it again
I was like "Uh-oh", I took
it again and they said
"We're sorry, you are
96% Irish"
which is entirely too high
and I know that right now
minorities feel really displaced
and disrespected
but I face a very different
threat, if this gets out
I could be farmed into a sexual
breeding programme by
the alt-right
"Oh great news, we found a
really, really, really
white one"
Hurry, hurry, she's running
out of time to have another baby